[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we got our poll question
it's pretty blunt right to the point you
can uh give it to us seton one more time
why did bruce arian step down as the
head coach of the buccaneers health and
family or tom brady
how about health family this is the
right time
or tom brady okay all right let's bring
in rick stroud covers the buccaneers for
the tampa bay times how would you answer
that poll question rick
uh given those two choices probably the
second choice which is health family and
this is the right time
because maybe tom brady would prefer it
um
listen uh i i don't believe in
coincidences and and i know
you know there's a lot of truth and
bruce is very magnanimous here but to
just hand over
a super bowl ready team upon learning
that tom brady is unretiring um doesn't
exactly uh pass the smell test for me he
seemed willing to coach kyle trask and
blaine gabbard for god sakes so you know
all of this i think there's there's
elements of truth to all of it um but i
know this organization and at some point
the glazers would have had a meeting
with jason light
we know how influential tom is i don't
think this is totally on him
but they would have wanted to know what
the succession plan was
look he's going to be 70 october 3rd he
wasn't going to coach forever so there
is an element of the timing of this
makes an awful lot of sense both for
aryans and for the organization they
secure todd bowles for the next five
years
what do you think okay bruce's reasons
are why are what
that we know of well
that that i know of it's uh really
primarily he thinks it's the perfect
time um he's loyal to these guys on his
staff if he if he coached this year and
brady plays one season regardless of how
it ends the band breaks up right he's
had these guys in case of bulls 30 years
clyde christensen um you know armstrong
all of them together they go back to
temple for god's sakes as players many
of them and so you know when todd didn't
get hired that that upset him he thought
that both him and byron left would get
jobs um so this is a way to set up his
friend what's what's really confusing
about it is that that you would do it um
in a year where you can win another
super bowl which you think about his
legacy and maybe he's not that concerned
but two super bowl wins uh really helps
you with the pro football hall of fame
he may get there anyway
he certainly has a legacy of helping
minorities uh in football and and
females as well um but man this there
are very few
head coaches regardless of age or health
that would that would cash in at this
point with the hand that he has with tom
brady coming back so you have to think
that brady um at least put his finger on
the scale if not
i don't think he outright demanded it
but he certainly was influenced by it
bruce arians will be 70 at the beginning
of october pete carroll will be 71 in
the middle of september i was wondering
about this and uh i'll take you back to
when we saw tom at the soccer match in
london with the glazers
and at the time i thought
i don't know if tom's saying you know
i've always wanted to go to a manchester
united soccer match now's the time to do
it it felt like maybe he was asking
permission
to be traded to the 49ers that was my
original thought and then the other part
was
is he asking or
saying i'd like to come back and then
asking for some things when he comes
back
not thinking that he'd be asking for
todd bowles to be elevated into the head
coaching position what did you make of
that meeting what do you think happened
at that meeting and did it have an
impact on what happened
yesterday well i'm told that trip was
planned uh before his announcement but
again we'd be naive to not think there
was a reason he wanted to be with the
blazers the timing you know was the day
before he made the announcement on the
eve of three agency he would have had to
have told them uh and they did in fact
tell them long before that at least a
few days before the announcement that he
wanted to come back um but you know
being in person with the glazers who he
thinks highly of they've said no to him
never
really and listen to everything that
he's requested and granted it for the
most part um so again i i don't think
any i don't believe in coincidences dan
not in this league uh not in this
lifetime you know i've seen some pretty
amazing things with this organization i
saw john gruden get fired three weeks
after going nine and seven and you know
and and uh winning a super bowl uh a
couple years before that um you know
it it just never ceases to amaze me but
tom brady would have had to have had at
least
at the very least would have granted his
wish that this is okay with him if not
more than okay
um so i think everybody kind of wins
here in a way bruce aries gets to stay
around the organization he gets to drive
his golf cart around practice and and
help out uh wherever he can and todd
boltz gets to be a head coach so i think
they're all pretty happy with that
result but come on now we we know we
know tom brady's impact and influence on
this organization
i was also wondering this that you got
todd bowles getting another chance he
was the jets head coach
tom has a great relationship with byron
leftwich
his offensive coordinator whatever his
title is why not
get him promoted to head coach instead
of todd
well again you mentioned he does have a
good grasp and a good relationship with
byron leftwich but he also would know
whether byron leftwich is ready to be a
head coach
again if you're talking about tom
brady's
influence and input uh if you ask tom
brady i would assume he would tell you
that byron probably isn't there yet i
mean they've had to work through a lot
of things as an offensive coordinator i
think byron would tell you he's learned
an awful lot of football from tom brady
who's done a good portion of the game
planning those two have worked together
bruce was not really part of that
structure and as much as it was his
offense but those two are really the
ones that have put this thing together
offensively to make it brady's offense
so
i think tom would know that of the two
guys that were sitting in front of him
that todd bowles who has been a head
coach
he's watched his defense that he's much
more
prepared at this juncture at least to
lead his team to a super bowl look i
would this other thing i want to mention
is that
it it doesn't
the timing is bad but
remember tony dungy did this too with
jim caldwell you know tony dungy had a
super bowl team
it was the same guy peyton manning he
walked away and jim caldwell was a
coaching waiting they went to a super
bowl they didn't win it so tony dungy
wanted to leave his team and his coach
in the best position possible so it's
not unprecedented with a guy that worked
right here in tampa
it'll get even wilder the only way this
gets stranger if antonio brown comes
back for the buccaneers
that's it um i was also wondering what
is it that you think that brady brady
maybe didn't want bruce arians to let
let's just i maybe it's not being fair
to the situation but the
hypothetical of
why tom wouldn't want bruce arians as
his head coach anymore
that's a tough one for me because i
again i think him and tom from what we
could see had a good relationship um
maybe he would require a more hands-on
guy you know i mean look bruce was a ceo
head coach here in tampa bay um he did
not sit in on every meeting he did not
stay until midnight to say the very
least
some details were probably uh you know
left
left to pass without being taken care of
especially on offense
and you know look who he played for bill
belichick who was an absolute control
freak
bruce was not at that point in his
career he was not going to do those
things here in tampa he wasn't he
mentioned he might call plays a little
bit during the off-season but that
really wasn't anything he was interested
in and and so i think that you know
brady would probably
um was probably surprised by bruce's
lack of input at times and all i could
surmise is that you know if he does have
a problem he said he wants somebody to
be more on the details um hold people
more accountable and also you know there
was some language too i mean we remember
some of the things bruce said about tom
it was blunt it was raw um even as
recently as the combine when he said uh
he wouldn't trade him for anything but
five number one picks and that you know
sending him to another team would be
quote bad business so you wonder how all
those comments sort of get back to brady
and how he receives them
we had bruce on december 14th last year
and we discussed retirement this is how
it went
who retires first
you or him
that's a good that's a good one we'll
have to wait and see on that one
wait how about a package deal
yeah that might be a good that might be
a good way to ride out together
it made sense
and then when i and i'm just joking
because i didn't have any idea but i
just thought okay how long's tom play
how long is bruce coach and i never
would have thought that tom would be
playing longer than bruce would be
coaching
well i mean technically tom retired
first and he i'm retired
and maybe bruce will retire i don't know
i don't know what retirement means for
anybody anymore um you'll have to get an
answer to that one but yeah it is it is
really uh interesting that that it
played out the way it did and and i you
know again i i just don't think that you
walk away
if you're bruce arians i mean you got a
gift from the gods tom brady wants to
come back and quarterback your team he
he comes in at a time that gets all the
free agents resigned you're ready to go
you have a weak nfc really when you look
at all the quarterbacks in the afc i
remember him saying that andy reid would
coach kelly's 90 as long as patrick
mahomes is there that was bruce's
opinion so why bruce would walk away now
only he knows but uh i guess we got to
take him out his word at least for now
is he meeting with the media today
i don't think bruce is i know todd
bowles will be introduced as a head
coach and so and he's gonna you know at
this point i think he would fade to
black it's also interesting dan and i i
love
you know
i love sam farmer and peter king but
you know call a beat writer once in a
while that'd be good but
you know at the end of the day he
controlled the message he got in front
of the news he hadn't even contacted his
players yet
by text to let them know before the news
was you know was coming out or was about
to come out so he wanted to control this
message and i think that's telling in
and of itself
is that your first question for bruce
when you see him at a press conference
why didn't you give me the scoop
absolutely i thought we had a good
relationship uh i you know i don't take
a backseat to those guys but hey
i'm just there every day so not that i'm
better dan not in this business
you can't be bitter you got to be better
there you go thank you rick great to
talk to you again
good seeing you dad that's rick stroud
covers the box for the tampa bay times
host of uh sports day tampa bay podcast